we'll apply the upgrade now or later
that is the big question right who
hasn't gotten that message on all of
their devices their phones their tablets
yeah well what you might not know is
that putting that upgrade off for later
can have some serious consequences Brian
Loftus explains in today's cyber safe
parent
clicking the update later button on our
devices many do it and it's a welcome
mat for hackers make sure you go into
your applications and you update those
as soon as you can in that update is
something called a security patch its
purpose to locate and address
vulnerabilities security patches are
things that different vendors
specifically those that provide like
Computer Applications or other web-based
services that they routinely do with
with programs that you have installed on
your computer problem is for you your
family your company a lot of folks don't
take that simple step to keep the
security patch in action the biggest
thing to keep in mind is you want to
make sure you're running the current
version reason being is the security
patch is baked into the update you delay
the update hackers get an Open Door
whether that's ransomware variants
spyware malware basically any type of a
virus or something bad that could hurt
your computer or steal your information
for businesses this is essential as
companies and vendors learn about those
they do what's called patch updates and
that's basically where they're updating
uh the software or the programming kind
of the back end what you don't see to
allow so that those exploits or
vulnerabilities are no longer there so
if a cyber criminal does hack into a
computer once the the company learns
about it then they they patch that and
they basically block it off lastly never
update your device in an untrusted
Network at the coffee shop or airport
and business owners staff up your it
Department most I.T professionals are up
to speed on this Brian Loftis live local
now